Globally. We are much better off than we used to be, of course,
in a well of well advanced countries, rich countries, people are much richer,
but the world as a whole is getting richer, which is why poverty has declined.
Absolute poverty has declined for about 90% of humanity in 1800 to less
than 8% today. I just want to repeat that in 1800, just 200 years ago,
90% of people lived on $2 per person per day.
Today, roughly 8% of people live on $2 per person per day.
So, um, yes, the,
the great increase in the richest has resulted in a substantial
reduction in, uh, in absolute poverty.
We have seen a billion people rise from absolute poverty in China in the last 40
or 50 years, we are seeing India coming up.
We are seeing a number of African countries growing at 5% per year. Um,
there there's a lot of good news that's happening in the world.
Right.
To the, the top 10 that you talk about here,
but the book has 78 trends that are going well.
So we're going to plow through this top 10, and then I'm just going to,
I'm going to quiz you on a couple of random ones as well,
but I'm going to go through them right here.
So the first trend that you guys have is the great enrichment.
And this is basically about the economy. So can you lay this out?
Because a lot of people think we're, we're poor. The divide is worse than ever,
and we seem to be getting poor, but it's actually not true.
Since the historical record begun. Um,
people lived on about $2 per person per day,
2000 years ago at the time of Christ or Caesar Augustus people in America,
in Europe, in Africa, anywhere in the world,
lived on $2 a day or so that is why today.
When we talk about absolute poverty about living at a subsistence level,
we talk about that $2 level because that's how people used to live
since the Dawn of time. Really. Um,
now bringing it back to all,
bringing it forward all the way to 18 hundreds at the time of Thomas Jefferson
presidency,
global income per capita per day is only $2 and 80.
So it's still very, very low. But today 200 years later,
it is $44 per person per day,
globally in the United States is roughly $160 per person per
day. And if, um, if the current trends continue,
if we are able to repeat the growth that we had over the last hundred years and
projected to 2100,
then Everage global income will be $144 per person per
day. So from $2, since the Dawn of time,
two $44 today to about 150 in 2100,
that's the,
of the tremendous economic growth that we have experienced in the last 200
years, and that we can still experience in the future.
So I think one of the things that confuses people,
at least when we hear this through the mainstream media is they're the I there's
this idea that the rich keep getting richer and that the poor are getting
poorer. But,
but the argument that you're laying out in essence is not that the rich aren't
getting richer, many rich people are getting richer,
but that the entire pool is actually being raised at the same time.
So the lowest person is in far better shape now than they were
say 200 years ago.
That's correct. Uh,
the data which are just presented our data based on global average,
which is to say a person living maybe somewhere in Indonesia or Malaysia,
right in the middle of the pack, they there, the data is not distorted,
uh, by, uh, by, you know,
looking at just very rich people and high income inequality,
or what have you globally. We are much better off than we used to be, of course,
in a well of well advanced countries, rich countries, people are much richer,
but the world as a whole is getting richer, which is why poverty has declined.
Absolute poverty has declined for about 90% of humanity in 1800 to less
than 8% today. I just want to repeat that in 1800, just 200 years ago,
90% of people lived on $2 per person per day
today, roughly 8% of people live on $2 per person per day.
So, um, yes, the, the great increase in,
in richest has resulted in a substantial reduction in, uh,
in absolute poverty.
We have seen a billion people rise from absolute poverty in China in the last 40
or 50 years, we are seeing India coming up.
We are seeing a number of African countries growing at 5% per year. Um,
there there's a lot of good news that's happening in the world,
or at least there was before COVID.
And since, uh, this election is a week away,
we should talk about the forces that make all of that happen.
It has a little something to do with free markets, right?
That's correct.
The greatest decline in absolute poverty in the world is a
core Terminus.
Whereas the opening of the global economy after 1980,
this is called the period of globalization. Now I realized that a lot of people,
including a lot of people in United States are ambivalent about globalization,
but there is no doubt that once these formerly poor countries
dropped socialism and central planning embraced free markets,
embraced multinational corporations and inward foreign investment.
Once that happened, these countries started to grow at a much faster pace,
which is why today places like China are middle income countries. Uh,
they are no longer dirt poor. I mean, at the time of mal,
these people literally ate dirt today. They're sending people to the moon, well,
least the space. So my work is that working out the last,
the last 40 years have been exceptionally good,
especially for poor countries.
Yeah. All right. Let's go to number two here,
which is really an offshoot of this, that in many ways,
we're at the end of poverty.
Absolute poverty. Yes. As you well know in the United States, uh,
we no longer have absolute poverty. Nobody lives on $2 per day.
Even people who don't have a job, uh,
can access food and all sorts of facilities, which are provided by the taxpayer,
but globally, um, absolute poverty had been,
or was before COVID at its lowest. It has ever been,
which is to say less than 8%. And now of course,
as countries become richer, they start to redefine poverty in a different way,
which is why in the United States.
We don't talk about absolute poverty when we talk about poverty.
So relative problem poverty,
it's a certain percentage of the mean national income that we consider.
If people live under that they are in poverty, but,
but we don't have absolute poverty in the United States.
You know, from someone sitting where I am in Los Angeles,
where I'm seeing many more homeless people than there were a couple of
years ago,
we know that this is happening in a lot of the big cities in Portland,
in Seattle, certainly in San Francisco. I think people see that, you know,
you see tent cities, you see more homeless people, et cetera, et cetera. And,
and the inclination is, Oh, well, I'm seeing something. So it must be,
it must be significantly worse than it was. Um,
but is it, is it just that that's happening in just some cities or,
or is it just that your anecdotal evidence doesn't really prove anything?
Well, uh, whether you look at, uh, poverty as a, as a relative measure,
relative poverty as a percentage of national income,
or what do you look at consumption poverty. In other words,
how much do people actually spend on, uh, on monthly basis, a weekly basis,
poverty is an all-time low.
I suspect that what's happening in places like San Francisco and Los Angeles is
that new policies have been implemented by local governments,
which make it more attractive for, uh, for,
for people who, um,
may not be necessarily interested in, in,
in jobs may not necessarily be interested in normal, uh, lifestyles,
people who may, for whatever reason prefer the, um, the, the,
the, the freedom, essentially of not being tied to any, any, uh,
anything concrete and want to live in these 10 cities and who may have been
living in those 10 cities throughout the United States. But for whatever reason,
because the policies of local governments are now changed.
These people are being pulled like a magnet towards certain jurisdictions.
And that's why you see many more of them. That would be, I think,
one reason why, why you see that anecdotally?
Yeah. And we do know by the way that they're,
they're putting in policies in places like San Francisco and Los Angeles that
are attracting more homeless people.
It's not something that you're just making up at one point, there was a policy.
I'm not sure if we still have it in Los Angeles,
where if you build a structure on public land, they can't remove it.
You got an awful lot of people paying,
paying mortgages on land that they bought.
I don't know what we're doing over here.
I would simply add just to clarify one comment I made in my last, uh, um,
contribution. And that is that, uh,
when I say that people don't necessarily want to have a home and work
for a living, et cetera, it, I'm not making a value judgment.
I'm saying that there is a,
there are a lot of people who have very different conceptions about what a good
life is. And also in addition to that,
there are a lot of people who may be mentally unstable, uh,
who have all sorts of mental ill problems that prevents them from keeping a job
and remaining in one place, um, at, at, at the same time.
Right? So, and naturally you're saying there,
there are things potentially that government or private citizens can do for
those people, but that overall, this, this is working and.
Well. Uh, well, there, there are two sides of the ledger. On the one hand,
you want to do something for people, uh,
who are the very bottom of society on the other hand, uh,
that shouldn't mean that you make life unlivable, uh,
for people who live in the cities and who actually pay taxes.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversation about the
environment, instead of nonstop yelling, check out our environment playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.